>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington, DC.
>> Thea Austen: Welcome everybody.
Thank you so much for coming today.
It's great to see you all.
I see so many familiar faces,
but welcome to all of you.
I'm Thea Austen, the
public events coordinator
for the American Folklife Center
at the Library of Congress,
and on behalf of our entire
staff, I want to welcome you
to this first concert in
the 2016 Homegrown Music
of America concert series.
This is a little unusual
because these folks are actually
from the republic of Georgia,
but we welcome them in our hearts
as if they are our own people.
This concert series 2016 is in the
year, the 40th anniversary year
of the creation of the
America Folklife Center,
that's what I wanted to say, and we
have a number of concerts, lectures,
and other special events planned
to celebrate the 40th anniversary.
So stay tuned.
Ooh, so many people coming in.
Well there are a few empty
seats, so please come in
and you'll see little spots.
It's so great to see you all.
This is a very special concert,
and I'm sure you're
really going to enjoy it.
I want to also thank
the Library's African
and Middle East division
for cosponsoring this.
Mary-Jane Deeb, the
chief of the division,
in particular for cosponsoring, and
Lee Avdoyan, who is our Armenian
and Georgian specialist, who
is here, I saw him earlier.
I know he's here somewhere.
Oh, there you are.
So anyway, thanks to Ahmed
for cosponsoring this concert.
Our performance today is going to
be recorded for the collections
and is going to be webcast.
You'll be able to see it online
when it's edited and put up online.
It'll be there in perpetuity and
accessible anywhere in the globe
where you have an internet
connection.
So this is a good time
to so this is a good time
to silence your cell
phones or anything else
that makes a beeping noise
or else you will too be
archived in perpetuity.
We have some guests from the Embassy
of Georgia coming although I
don't think they're here yet,
so we will welcome
them when they come.
Today, we have a performance
of traditional polyphony
from the Republic of Georgia,
presented by the Anchiskhati Choir,
one of the world's
leading exponents,
if not the leading exponent of the
Georgian polyphonic choral music.
To tell you more about them, I'm
going to introduce Dr. John Graham.
John currently lectures in the
music department at Yale University
as a research fellow attached to
the Yale Institute of Sacred Music
where he also directs
a Georgian chant choir.
His PhD at Princeton University,
"The Transmission and Transcription
of Georgian Liturgical Music"
encompassed a comprehensive
investigation of the
written and audio sources
for liturgical chant tradition
of the Georgian Orthodox Church,
both medieval and modern,
which has been difficult
at times, as you will find out.
Anyway, please welcome John Graham.
[ Applause ]
>> John A. Graham: Good
afternoon, thank you everybody
for coming out at your lunch break.
We have a wonderful
performance in store,
and I will just give some
prefatory remarks today,
and then I will also introduce
various elements of the program
in between some of the selections.
To begin with, as you
can see in the program,
the Anchiskhati Church Choir is
very important in the revival
of traditional repertories and also
performance practice in Georgia.
These two are separate.
For the liturgical tradition, which
was banned through the Soviet period
from 1921 until 1990,
the Anchiskhati Choir
has been instrumental
in recovering this traditional
repertory from archival sources.
These sources are transcriptions
that were written
in European notation in the
1880's and 1890's and survived
in the archives but were rarely
studied and were not published.
So the Anchiskhati Choir learned of
these archives, transcribed them,
began singing them in
the Anchiskhati church,
which is the oldest basilica in
Tbilisi, the capital of Georgia,
and began publishing chant
books starting in 2000
as well as CD recordings.
And from these books and
recordings a whole generation
of chanters have learned this
ancient medieval repertory
that was passed through oral
transmission for centuries.
So these gentlemen that will be here
on stage are really considered
the teachers of my generation
of chanters in Georgia of
which there are hundreds,
perhaps thousands.
So it's really an honor and a
privilege to have them here today.
Now in the Soviet period,
sacred chant was sung,
but it was mostly a
composed repertory.
Composers composed simple-style
harmonies to basic melodies
on the Georgian Orthodox
liturgical texts,
and they also performed this
music in a European choral style,
so this was well blended
voices, mixed gender choirs,
a large vocal range, etc., which
is quite different than the way
that traditional performance was
actually performed, both folk music
and liturgical music in
the pre-Soviet period.
So one thing that the Anchiskhati
Choir has done in addition
to reviving this traditional
repertory,
is to go back to the
oldest audio recordings
and to closely examine the ways that
the singers perform their music.
And it turns out that instead of
large choirs, they had small choirs.
Instead of multiple people
singing each voice part,
they would have a soloist singing
the top voice and the middle voice
with perhaps a group
singing the lowest
of the three-part vocal tradition.
And the reason that
they had soloists is
so that the upper two voice
parts could improvise,
because it's an oral traditional,
and like many oral traditions
around the world, there's this
element of variation technique
and improvisation,
which is fundamental
to the performance of the music.
And this is where liturgical
music intersects with folk music.
The folk repertory is
largely improvised.
Often there are texted
verses contrasted by choruses
of nonsense syllables, or what we
call vocables, and it's precisely
on the vocables that you hear
improvisation, and we're going
to hear those elements
today in the program sung
by the Anchiskhati Choir.
So for their traditional
performance practice,
they have soloists singing
the upper voice parts
so that they can improvise.
They sing in more of a natural
voice, a natural timbre, let's say,
that doesn't or tries to avoid any
influences from choral technique
that we associate with the great
Russian choral schools that came
into Georgia in the 19th Century--
what we call generally a Bel canto
style or European choral style.
So what you'll hear today is more of
a bright kind of earthy folk style
of singing both in the folk
music and the liturgical music,
and this style has been revived from
the old recordings and goes together
with the traditional repertory.
So those are just some
teasers for you to listen
for as we get going
with the performance.
Okay, so now a word
about where is Georgia.
I know this is a very educated
audience here in the Library
of Congress, but still, I
include it just to mention
that we're not talking
about the state of Georgia.
Neither are we talking
about Gregorian chant.
So please don't ask me about
Gregorian chant after the show.
This is Georgian chant of the
Orthodox rite, and as you can see
on this little map that I've
included over on the screen
on the right, Georgia is a
very mountainous country.
The Caucasus mountain range,
which stretches from the Black Sea
to the Caspian Sea is the northern
geographical border of Georgia
and historically separated
Georgia culturally and politically
from the steppes to the north.
As well, if you look to the south,
the eastern Anatolian plateau is
also a massive mountain range.
And these mountains are higher
than the Rockies and Alps,
so it's a significant
geographical barrier.
And within these mountains there
are many, many different cultures.
Just in Dagestan alone I believe
there are 29 mutually distinct
languages and culture groups.
The Persians called this area
the mountain of languages,
and within Georgia there are four
languages that are closely related
but mutually unintelligible.
Think of French to
Italian to Spanish.
So there are four languages
like that
in a group called the
Kartvelian language group,
and these are not Indo-European,
and they have no analogue
elsewhere in the world.
Georgian culture goes
back 5000 years.
They say that wine was
invented in Georgia,
and indeed they found grape pips
and buried amphoras in Georgia
and in the Armenian region,
which is a source of great pride
for all Georgians, and in fact
today it's still a living tradition.
Many villagers, many people take
pride in making their own wine
in their own buried
amphoras in their backyards.
So there's a great viniculture
tradition, which goes hand in hand
with singing as we all know,
so that's why I mentioned it.
A political map from
the mid-20th Century.
You can see that Georgia is bordered
to the south by Turkey, Armenia
and Azerbaijan, to the north by the
various North Caucasian Republics
such as Chechnya, Ingushetia,
Kabardino, Balkaria
and various other states that are
now part of the Russian federation.
When we talk about music, we talk
about 12 regions within Georgia
that have their own distinct
dialects, cuisine, clothing,
and musical styles, and these
musical styles have something
in common, which is that they
are mostly all three-part harmony
folk-singing traditions.
There are folk instruments, but
they generally accompany a singing
tradition, which is
almost always polyphonic,
and that distinguishes Georgian
folk music from other music systems
in the area, which are
mostly monophonic; that is,
highly ornamented solo lines that
are played on instruments or sung
by vocalists, but the
Georgian music is polyphonic,
so this is a big difference.
Now within Georgia we have as
I mentioned the 12 regions,
and I've designed the program
today such that we'll be starting
in East Georgia, and we'll be
hearing a chant or two, two chants,
and then a folk song from East
Georgia, and what I'd ask you
to listen to are the ways in which
the harmony of the folk music
and chant resemble one
another in this region.
And then as we move into
central Georgia and then finally
to West Georgia you'll hear how
the harmony of both the folk
and sacred music influence
one another.
So it's most scholars opinion that
Greek monophonic chant melodies came
into Georgia maybe as
early as the fourth century
when Georgia converted
to Christianity,
but it's through a process
of vernacularization
of both the biblical
text and the way
that those biblical texts were
performed in the ritual services
that probably very early on these
monophonic melodies imported
from Jerusalem and Antioch would
have been sung in polyphony.
So the dating of when
this polyphony,
or polyphonic vernacularization,
occurred is under debate.
Some scholars say it was as early as
the fourth, fifth, sixth centuries.
Other scholars say there's no
evidence, maybe it happened
in the middle ages, the 10th, 11th
centuries, but you get the idea.
This is a very old, polyphonic
performance of liturgical melodies,
which is unique to this
eastern segment of Christianity.
Of course Russian polyphony
exists but it occurs much later.
We'll have a Question and Answer
session afterwards, so I'm putting
out a lot of teasers, and
I know there will be a lot
of questions having to do with this.
So we'll start with East Georgia,
which is on the map
the area indicated
by these monasteries here...
if this doesn't work...
but numbers four, five, and six, and
then later in the program we'll go
to the monastery, Gelati Monastery,
number three, in central Georgia,
and finally to the
Shemokmedi Monastery,
number one, on the Black Sea Coast.
So, at this point, let's welcome
the ensemble to the stage,
and here's some Georgian polyphony.
[ Applause ]
[ Background Noise ]
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
[ Background Noise ]
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
[ Background Noise ]
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
So now we'll move to Central
Georgia, and I'll just say quickly
that in East Georgia, what we just
heard, you hear drone polyphony.
You hear this strong bass
drone in the lowest voice part.
As we move across the Central
Georgian mountains into the west,
you don't hear that anymore.
So in this next little section,
you'll hear more improvisation
within the bass voice, but what
we'll lose a little bit is the
ornamentation in the upper voices.
In East Georgia you have all these
beautiful little elaborations
and ornamentations
in the solo parts,
and in West Georgia
you have less of that.
It's a little more specific
to the pitch choices,
but you have more improvisation
in all three voices,
not just the upper two.
So now to Central Georgia,
the Gelati Monastery School
and a folk song from Samegrelo,
which is a nearby region.
[ Background Noise ]
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
[ Background Noise ]
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
[ Background Noise ]
[ Music ]
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
Before we move to West Georgia,
I'll just say a quick
note about the instrument.
This is the chonguri, a four-string
lute that we find in West Georgia,
all the West Georgian regions,
that has one fixed string.
So it's like a banjo.
The actual strumming is on three
strings, but it's unfretted,
which allows the instrument
to accommodate the unique
Georgian intonation system,
which we'll be talking about a
little bit later in the Q and A.
So now as we move to far Western
Georgia, these are the hills
of Guria and Achara on
the Black Sea coast.
This area of the country was
sometimes under Ottoman control
for the last 400 years,
sometimes under Georgian control.
First we'll hear the Kriste
Aghdga, Christ is Risen.
We'll hear three versions
as recorded in 1966,
by the last master chanter,
Artem Erkomaishvili.
So you'll hear the ways that he
plays with the model melodies,
the ways that he improvises
and varies his own melody.
And what I will say that
distinguishes this harmony
from the harmony that we've
been listening to so far is
that they love the dissonances in
the Shemokmedi Monastery region.
So you'll hear a lot of close second
intervals in the upper voices,
and he also loves wide
open fifth chords,
so the upper voices will
have an interval of a fifth
with another fifth below
it, what we call a ninth.
So you'll hear a lot of
this fifth-ninth harmony,
sometimes in parallel,
which is similar to tenth
and eleventh century polyphony
as it started in Europe,
but it quickly developed away, and
as we know from music theory 101,
no parallel fifths or octaves
are allowed in western music.
Well not in Georgia.
In Georgia they kept the parallel
fifths, octaves, and even ninths.
So now we're in far Western
Georgia, and after this,
in lieu of an intermission
as written in the program,
we will have a Question
and Answer session,
which will include the
choir singing a single chant
from all three schools,
a single text
so that you can hear how the
three schools fit together
under the banner of one text.
So thank you.
[ Background Noise ]
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
[ Background Noise ]
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
[ Background Noise ]
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
[ Background Noise ]
[ Music ]
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
So now just briefly, I'll introduce
the concept of the model melodies,
which I talked about a little bit
in the introduction and the ways
that these model melodies are
harmonized in all three regions.
So, again, I put up the map here.
We're going to start with singing
in the East Georgian version.
[ Foreign Language ]
Let's see, which do we
have in the program first?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
We have East Georgian.
Yes, so we're going to start
with the East Georgian version
of this chant, which is
the Troparion to St. Nino,
Enlightener of Georgians,
the one that brought
Christianity in the fourth century.
This is a chant that is sung
within the Orthodox rite
on feast days associated with
St. Nino, usually January 27.
So here are the model melodies
I put up on the screen.
I know they're small on
this screen, but basically,
you see what the first voice,
the top voice that we
hear, will be singing.
You see, there are six
phrases, and then the way
that these model melodies are
harmonized is what changes quite
drastically between
the three regions,
which I think we've
already demonstrated
in this program how
difficult the harmony can be
between the three regions.
Within tone four, within the genre
of Troparia assigned to tone four,
there are in fact more
model melodies
that could be used hypothetically.
I did a study of 17 different
Troparia assigned to tone four
and came up with a larger
segment of model melodies,
which I won't bore you
with, but essentially
when you have these 17
different texts here,
you can align the model
melodies in different orders
so you can pick and choose.
You can start with model melody
one, go to two, go to three,
or you can start with one and
jump to three, go to four,
and come back to two, etc.
So this is the way the Eight Mode
system works as it's been inherited
through oral transmission
in Georgia.
And this is of interest for
liturgical scholars and folks
that study chant transmission,
the Eight Mode system,
so it manifested itself in different
ways in the various centers
of Christianity, whether in Milan,
Rome, Spain, St. Gall, Jerusalem,
the various Eastern churches such
as Ethiopia, Coptic Egypt, etc. So,
without more introduction,
let's hear the choir sing the
three versions of this chant
that we've inherited
through oral transmission,
and you can see their
details in the program.
The first version was inherited
through the Karbelashvili master
chanter family in East Georgia.
It was transcribed by one member
named Vasili and published in 1898.
The second version was transcribed
in 1885 from three master chanters
in the Gelati Monastery
region, and the final version
that we'll hear was
again recorded in 1966
by that last master
chanter, Artem Erkomaishvili.
And the idea here is to hear
how the melody is similar,
but the harmonies are different, and
I think that will be quite obvious.
[ Background Noise ]
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
[ Background Noise ]
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
[ Background Noise ]
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
Let me take this opportunity to
introduce the members of the choir.
Here on your left is
David Shugliashvili.
He has a--
[ Applause ]
He has a doctorate in musicology.
He teaches at the Tbilisi
Conservatory.
His dissertation was on model
melodies, which is why I wanted
to bring this up, because
he is the world expert
on this particular aspect
of the Eight Mode system,
so if there are questions of
that, I'll ask him to answer.
And he also is a founding
member of the Anchiskhati Choir,
teaches in the chant school
of the Georgian Patriarchate
as do all the members here, and
works for the Patriarchate Library
as the head of division of
the audio/visual materials
for the library system, so
he's familiar with libraries.
Here we have Zaal Tsereteli--
[ Applause ]
Zaza is also a founding
member of the choir in 1988.
Actually he joined one
year later in 1989.
He is trained as a mathematician,
he works as a computer programmer,
and he supplied a mathematical
model that he developed himself
for studying the otherwise
undeciphered medieval neume system.
That is, the graphic symbols
that represent the
Georgian chant tradition
in 10th century manuscripts.
In the second half of the 10th
century we have six manuscripts
with this type of neume notation
which musicologists haven't been
able to figure out, but Zaza,
with statistical models, has come
up with some good theories for how
to look at these neume groupings
and how to make sort of sense
of what they mean, so
that's some of his work.
Next we have David Zatiashvili--
[ Applause ]
Dato [phonetic] is from East
Georgia and therefore specializes
in this East Georgian
ornamental technique,
but he has also developed
the krimanchuli yodeling
from West Georgia.
Zaza works for the
Georgian government;
or Dato works for the Georgian
government, in the division
of education and helps
develop curriculum
for the national school system.
He is a lifetime educator
and also a founding member
of Anchiskhati Choir.
And finally, Levan Veshapidze--
[ Applause ]
Levan trained as folklorist
in the conservatory
and continues to teach folk music.
He's published several
books and CDs especially
on Acharian and Gurian folk music.
As you can see, he
plays the chiboni,
which is the rare goatskin
bagpipe from the Achara mountains,
and Levan also teaches chant
and has the foremost theory
on the Georgian intonation system.
He devotes lots of time to
developing chants and folk songs
that are set in the
tuning, the original tuning,
and post these videos on YouTube,
so he's a leader in the new,
sort of our generation
of scholarship
on the intonation system.
So for these four members of
the larger Anchiskhati group,
let's welcome them once more.
[ Applause ]
And finally, before we transition
to a Question and Answer session,
I just wanted to speak a
little bit more briefly
about this intonation
system, this tuning system,
which I think is really
interesting and something
that Georgian music has to offer.
And since we have these experts
here, we might as well mention it.
There are various theories.
One is that there's an
octave species as you see
on this little graphic, where
certain pitches are tuned higher
or lower, and there's conjunct
and disjunct tetra chords.
Various theories map the
ancient Greek music theory
onto the Georgian scale.
Levan and Zaza's theory is
that the octave is divided
by equal heptatonic steps, so 7
steps in the scale instead of 12.
You can see from this little
graphic that I made up.
On the left you have
equal tempered tuning.
The darker shaded gray areas are
half steps, what we were familiar
with from guitar tuning, piano
tuning, etc. These are measured
by what we call cents [phonetic].
So a half step would be 100 cents,
as you see here dark shaded,
and a whole step would be
200 cents, or two half steps.
Meanwhile Georgian intervals
are more like 160 or 170 cents,
so they're neither half steps nor
whole steps, and we can hear this
in all of the recordings that
we have from the master singers
and master chanters,
especially Artem Erkomaishvili,
that we've heard from today.
So, I'm sorry the graphic
is a little bit small,
but if you see the darkest line,
horizontal lines, the
octaves are equal.
The fifth below the high octave,
it's about equal in the Georgian
and the tempered tuning,
but the pitches
that really differ are
the third and the sixth,
so this sort of comes close to
what we call just intonation
or baroque intonation in Europe,
where you have neutral
thirds and neutral sixths.
I'm not talking microtones, not
tiny tones, these are actually wider
than a half step, and what we get
are these kind of neutral chords
that neither feel minor nor major.
So with that, I'll ask
the Anchiskhati Choir
to sing one last folk song
in this intonation style,
and with that we'll sort of
close our program and open it
up to Q and A. Thank you.
>> If we can.
>> John A. Graham: Hum?
[laughter] Oh, he says, if we can.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Ah, yes. Okay.
Good idea, Zaza suggests
that we first hear the
scale as best we can manage.
So Levan, we'll volunteer
you to sing the scale.
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
So this is the song Odela
[phonetic] from Imereti [phonetic],
and it doesn't have a text.
It's just sung on vocables,
and as I mentioned before,
that allows for more improvisation.
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
Are there questions for me or
for any member of the group?
Yes sir?
>> Paul Crego: Could you remind
Indo Europeans that the O at the end
of St. Nino is not the
masculine [inaudible]
but St. Nino is actually a woman.
[laughter]
>> John A. Graham: Paul
Crego, who works here
and has long studied Georgian
language since 1977, right?
>> Paul Crego: Yes.
>> John A. Graham: Yes.
And so Paul writes on the life
and the hagiography of St. Nino,
and yes, St. Nino is
a woman [laughter].
Thank you, Paul.
Other questions?
Right here first.
>> Female audience member: Since we
pretend to sing Georgian litanies
in church, could you do one for us?
>> John A. Graham: So the question
is, in the Orthodox church,
even in the Orthodox
Church of America
where many repertoires are sung, we
sometimes sing Georgian litanies,
and would the choir
perform a Georgian litany.
[foreign language] So litanies are
"Lord have mercy" responses
to the deacon.
[ Singing ]
[ Foreign Language ]
[ Applause ]
They know literally
hundreds of the litanies.
>> Female audience
member: I was wondering
if we could have the
rest of the litany.
>> John A. Graham:
The entire litany?
[laughter]
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
And right here?
>> Female audience member:
I was going to cheat and ask
if we could have one more
piece of the [inaudible].
Thank you.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> John A. Graham: So here's a--
they have a massive repertory.
It's always so difficult to choose
from among so many good songs.
So this is one that they've been
doing on this tour to great acclaim,
and it's called Khasanbegura,
which is a historical ballad
recounting the Russian Turkish
conflicts in 1878.
So there was Georgian traitor,
and this song is about him,
so we remember who
the traitors were.
But really, that's just the text.
It's really an improvisatory
trio song.
It's supposed to be trio and choir.
Here they're going to do
both with just four singers,
and you'll hear a lot
of improvisation
within the trio part especially.
[ Background Noise ]
Dato wants me to mention to remind
you to listen for the yodel,
which this song features [laughter].
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
For those people that need to
leave early, I'll just mention
that any purchases of CDs or
books of notation goes not only
to support the choir
but to the revival
of traditional music in general.
So please see those at the
sales table in the back.
Yes, question here.
>> Audience member: Could
we finish with a chant
from [inaudible] [laughter].
>> John A. Graham: One more chant?
>> Audience member: Yes [inaudible].
>> John A. Graham:
Ah, the wedding chant.
[foreign language]
[ Background Noise ]
[ Foreign Language ]
Okay. By request they'll sing
now the famous wedding hymn
or Theotokia hymn, Shen Khar
Venakhi, from East Georgia.
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
I was just going to say that
we have this space until 1:30,
so we can just keep doing
the requests, open mic style,
or questions, and as you need
to leave, that's perfectly fine.
>> Audience member: Is it possible
that the vocables came
from instruments?
[ Foreign Language ]
>> John A. Graham: So Dato says
that the predominant form
of our music is vocal.
[ Foreign Language ]
The main function of the
folk instruments as far
as we can tell is to
accompany songs.
[ Foreign Language ]
The study of music and instrumental
music is extremely fascinating
in Georgia but it's
hard to say exactly
if they had different functions or
if one came before the other, etc.
[ Foreign Language ]
Other questions?
Yes?
>> Audience member: What are
the cigars in their costumes?
>> John A. Graham: Oh, I forgot
to answer my number one question!
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes, so the costume that they're
wearing is called a chokha.
It's not unique to Georgian culture.
It's a trans-Caucasian, all of the
various groups in the Caucuses,
all of the various groups in
the Caucuses wear some variant
of this chokha, which
is a military outfit
from the 17th and 18th centuries.
It has many different forms, many
different froms of embroidery,
etc., in the various regions.
Some of the common features are
that it's a tunic worn
outside the clothes with a belt
on the exterior of the tunic.
Usually they would have a
short dagger, long sword,
pistols, rifle, and [laughter]--
>> Audience Member: None of which
you could bring into the Library.
>> John A. Graham: Right.
[laughter] We couldn't
bring them in.
We tried to do that ten years
ago with Anchiskhati that year.
So at the breast are
premeasured amounts of gun powder
for their muskets or rifles.
Now they're ornamental.
Over here?
>> Audience member: Could you
please describe any feature
of music from Svaneti?
>> John A. Graham: Musical
features of music from Svaneti.
>> Audience member: Yes,
anything to inform the public.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> John A. Graham: So Dato says
that the region of Svaneti is one
of the mountain regions
in Western Georgia
where folklore was most protected,
so we still have singers there
who sing in the original
intonation style
who haven't been influenced
by other musical styles.
[ Foreign Language ]
And this music culture at Svaneti
is alive in all generations.
So the grandparents will sing,
and the grandchildren
will sing with them.
[ Foreign Language ]
And they have a particular style
of singing that's different
from all the other
regional styles as I said,
and I should mention they
also speak a unique language.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Was your question about the harmony,
or do you want to hear a Svan song?
[laughter]
>> Audience member:
[Inaudible] anything about Racha?
>> John A. Graham: And about Racha?
[ Foreign Language ]
So Racha is a neighboring
mountain region to Svaneti,
and these places are
fantastic to visit by the way.
If you can ever come
to Georgia, please.
So Racha, Dato says that Rachan
folklore is similar to Svan
in some ways, being a
neighbor mountain region,
but interestingly it also,
Rachan harmony also resembles
Eastern Georgian harmony,
which is very curious since it's a
Western Georgian mountain region,
possibly suggesting some sort
of cultural contact or some type
of movement of a population
at some point.
[ Foreign Language ]
So the choice is a Svanetian
para-liturgical hymn called Lile.
Lile was one of the gods in
the pantheon of [inaudible]
in Svaneti before Christianity
arrived.
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
Right here?
>> Audience member: What are some
of the characteristics of the music
that typically accompanies
dance traditions in Georgia?
[ Foreign Language ]
>> John A. Graham: As
everywhere, rhythm.
And also the instruments that
they play often accompany dance,
especially the bagpipe.
And they also have a
doli, the two-headed drum.
What else?
[ Foreign Language ]
Also the-- whenever
they start clapping,
that's usually an indication
that the young dancers will come
and dance in front of the choir.
And I'll mention that there's
a whole genre of songs,
especially from the mountains,
called rounds dance songs,
which were performed by the whole
family or the whole village,
and they could last for many,
many, many minutes usually
in an antiphonal type of setup
where there are two choirs
responding, one to another.
One has a verse, the other responds,
and they continue a round dance.
And the footwork is
often quite difficult.
It looks simple, but it's on a
different rhythm than the singing.
I know because I taught
my choir round dances,
and it was always very difficult.
[ Foreign Language ]
So Dato says that there are
a few famous dance companies
that have been big exports
from Georgia culturally,
so [foreign language] large
dance companies, and this is sort
of a professionalized version
of traditional dance steps,
but he says the more folk-style
authentic dance still exists,
especially in mountain
cultures like Svaneti.
[ Foreign Language ]
But we can't demonstrate that.
[laughter] Did you have--
>> Audience member: Are the neumes
in any way related to punctuation?
>> John A. Graham:
So the question is:
are neumes related to punctuation?
[ Foreign Language ]
So phrases in the tenth century
hymnographic text were divided
with punctuation.
[ Foreign Language ]
The other symbols in the Georgia
neume system are not necessarily
punctuation specific but have more
to do what we think
with melodic movement.
So there's various symbols, and
they'll be specifically placed
above the syllable on which
the melody needs to move
in one direction or another.
[ Foreign Language ]
Placed above, or below, the text.
That's an important element, which
distinguishes the Georgian system
from any other neume systems.
[ Foreign Language ]
Eleven symbols in the
10th century system.
[ Foreign Language ]
Zaza also wants to
mention that in addition
to the tenth century neume system
we have later neume systems
that have some resemblance
but are not the same.
These occur in 18th, 19th,
and 20th century sources.
Thank you for the hymnographic
question.
[laughter] I spent two chapters
on my dissertation on that.
It's a very complex and
interesting set of materials.
Yes sir?
>> Audience member: I noticed
they ended in unison, their songs.
Is there a reason why the secular
and the sacred are in unison?
[ Foreign Language ]
>> John A. Graham: So the
question is about unison finals
for both folk songs
and liturgical chant.
[ Foreign Language ]
So Dato says most phrases end either
with an open fifth or with unison.
[ Foreign Language ]
It's very rare that a phrase
would end, for example,
in another interval like an octave.
[ Foreign Language ]
So the liturgical system, Dato says,
has more rules, and one of the rules
that we observe in the
transcription record is
that the chants end in unison.
The majority of folk songs, he says,
often end with a fifth interval.
[ Foreign Language ]
Dato wants to bring
in some theology.
So there's an 11th, 12th
century philosopher, theologian,
who taught at Gelati
Monastery named Ioane Petritsi.
In one of his writings,
he makes this analogy
where the three voices
are like the Holy Trinity
and how the three becomes one,
so we see the analogy, Dato says,
in the chant where
three voices become one.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Audience member: Well that
brings up another question,
talk about [inaudible] voice
of the Holy Spirit in the text.
>> John A. Graham: So
what's the question?
>> Audience member: Well the
question is what was he referring
to, what were they referring to
in the song when they were talking
about the reed-like
voice of [inaudible].
[ Foreign Language ]
>> John A. Graham: Was that in one
of the texts they sang this evening?
>> Audience member: Yes.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> John A. Graham: Ah, okay.
So the question is about the text
of this, the Troparion to St. Nino
where the Apostle Andrew
is mentioned.
Now we're with you.
And the answer is that Apostle
Andrew is said to have visited
and proselytized on the
Black Sea coast in Georgia
and in fact martyred, I believe,
on the Black Sea coast
according to hagiography.
And so St. Nino follows
in his footsteps,
follows his voice in the Caucuses.
I believe that's what
the text is referring to.
[ Foreign Language ]
St. Nino continued the
work of Apostle Andrew.
Are we finished?
>> Thea Austen: So, yeah, I'd like
to have everybody thank John Graham
and the amazing Anchiskhati Choir.
[ Applause ]
Thank you so much.
It's such an honor to have
such amazing performers
and distinguished colleagues
for us today, and I also want
to thank Elene Khurtsilava from the
Embassy, from the Georgian Embassy,
who joined us today as well.
So thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.